wer weiß was mama du willst mir gar
nicht zu hören nee ich habe jetzt einen
eigenen job also brauche ich dich nicht
mehr okay
mehr brauche ich nicht auf den stress
erst mal eine shopping runde
es gibt da zu lachen
hast du mama nicht gerade gesagt dass du
nichts mehr von ihr brauchst du auch
weil ich mein eigenes geld ab schaut
hier von dem du jetzt alle kosten
abdecken muss was für kosten das
bisschen essen und schminke welchen
bezahlen können das bisschen essen gehe
lieber zu mama und entschuldige dich
wieder
niemals na gut gehen wir das mal durch
offene zum beispiel deine fixkosten fix
was da warst du jeden monat auf jeden
fall ausgehen muss ich möchte auf jeden
fall das fitnessstudio bezahlen und die
bahnkarte kostet auch was den oder hey
lass es doch weiter mein handy vertrag
20 oder 39 das handy muss ich auch noch
abbezahlen eigentlich müsstest du ja
noch miete und die ganzen nebenkosten
strom heizung alles bezahlen aber da
deine eltern kindergeld kriegen lasse
ich dir das mal sehr freundlich ich weiß
und jetzt die variablen kosten
das ist jetzt was variable kosten sind
die kosten die nicht jeden monat gleich
sind das heißt essen kinobesuche oder
freiwillige abos na das kann ja nicht
viel sein
was ist denn so essen haha ich meine wie
viel
rechnen wir fünf euro ganz niedrig fünf
euro am tag x 30 tagen gemacht 150 euro
an essen hätte ist echt nicht fair und
wenn ich einfach weniger ist kaum noch
schminken shampoo dieser ganze andere
kleinkram dazu was wahrscheinlich bei 50
euro ungefähr liegt bleiben wir aber nur
noch 20 euro zum shoppen na da war viel
spaß es muss noch für kino reichen fürs
essengehen fürs tanzen gehen
meine lehrerin will am montag das
material geld einsammeln und das sind
genau 20 euro